[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce jeudi 25 janvier et 19
villes des yvelines pointés du doigt
pour leur manque de logements sociaux la
fondation abbé pierre la dévoiler
dans son dernier palmarès pourtant d'ici
2025 les communes soumises à la loi sru
devront avoir au moins 25 % de logements
sociaux reportage aux clayes-sous-bois
et à voisins-le-bretonneux mieux
encadrer le phénomène airbnb cette
plateforme qui vous permet de trouver
des locations meublées sur de courtes
durées versailles a adopté une
délibération en ce sens objectif affiché
protéger l'hôtellerie et le marché
l'immobilier classique pour en parler
philippin est notre invité les le
président de l'umih 78
et puis joey starr au théâtre montansier
à versailles hier soir il était à la
fiche de la pièce éloquence à
l'assemblée à l'artiste qui accaparent
les grands discours qui ont fait
l'histoire de l'assemblée nationale
entretien exceptionnel à suivre dans
cette édition
mais avant de développer ses titres pic
de crue prévu ce week-end à paris c'est
également le cas en aval bien sûr dans
les yvelines
le département se prépare à des
inondations sur ces images de patrick
jacques de dixmude et quentin le frère
vous voyez l'île de la loge à bougival
déjà en partie les pieds dans l'eau le
barrage de chatou a relevé une hauteur
de la scène frôlant les 5 mètres alors
des dernières inondations de 2016 l'eau
était montée à cinq mètres 40
plusieurs communes laisse donc actif
leur plan communal de sauvegarde qui
prévoit notamment des fermetures de
voies de circulation et les yvelines
toujours placé ce soir en vigilance
orange pluie inondation et ce jusqu au
moins à 20 heures elle regrette un
manque de volonté manifeste dans son
palmarès 2014 2016 la fondation abbé
pierre
épinglé lille mauvais élèves en terme de
logements sociaux 19 sont concernés dans
les yvelines
la loi sru pour la solidarité le
renouvellement urbain contre 1 pourtant
elle est commune à des minima
reportage à saint quentin en yvelines 2
nicolas kirillovitch pas assez de
logements sociaux aux clayes-sous-bois
alors c'est la préfecture des yvelines
qui reprend la main la loi est claire
d'ici 2025 les villes soumises aux
dispositifs sru devront avoir 25 % de
logements sociaux
et si elle ne respecte pas le rythme de
construction les sanctions tombent
pénalités financières et droit de
préemption urbain pour l'état autrement
dit la préfecture récupère le contrôle
pour la réalisation de logements sociaux
une injustice pour la mère des
clayes-sous-bois et ne lui manque que 11
logements pour respecter le seuil des
25%
on a beaucoup un sentiment de colère et
d'injustice face à la demie surtout face
à l'administration et à son regard sur
la réalité de ce que l'on vit ce que
vivent les maires dans les communes on
est traité un peu comme des gens qui ont
comme on dirait qu'ils mettent à font
preuve de mauvaise volonté mais c'est
pas du tout enfin c'est pas le cas dans
le département des yvelines 19 communes
sont particulièrement mis en cause pour
leurs manquements à la loi 79 ans tout
sur la région ile de france la loi sru
vise principalement à rééquilibrer sur
le territoire le parc hlm
un dispositif que la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux l 16 % de
logements sociaux soit très voir
appliquée à l'échelle de l'agglomération
quand la ville nouvelle a été créée par
son voisin était vu comme le quartier
résidentiel qui devait accueillir des
pavillons pour qu'en fait on hérite
d'une histoire qu'on nous reproche
aujourd'hui
et ce n'était pas un choix de l'époque
celle de l'état lui même qui a fait le
choix de répartir différents quartiers
comme ça sur 50 ans lundi un projet de
loi logement sera dévoilé au mois de
mars prochain le gouvernement pourrait
alors décider d'assouplir dans certains
cas la loi sru à 8,3 millions de
voyageurs en france dans ces logements
en 2016 airbnb a battu des records de
fréquentation à la plateforme comme
d'autres du genre propose des locations
meublées sur de courts séjours et face à
ce phénomène la ville de versailles a
récemment pris à des dispositions le but
notamment ses protégés l'hôtellerie
bonsoir philippins bonsoir vous êtes le
président de l'unis 78 c'est l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
vous êtes également hôtelier à
versailles alors versailles qui a adopté
donc cette délibération qui concerne
directement ces plateformes type airbnb
elle soumet à un propriétaire une
compensation dès qu'ils louent un meublé
d'au moins de 20 qu'il y aura un meublé
au moins de pardon thilo en meublé au
moins deux appartements on va y arriver
la délibération en fait assoupli une
précédente délibération a été pris en
septembre et elle prévoit notamment la
création d'un observatoire du meublés
touristiques
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces mesures
prises par la ville prise par la ville
de versailles que du bien je pense que
le maire a bien compris les enjeux et
les conséquences de cette montée en
flèche de ce type d'hébergement
je dois dire en créant but que tu sois
sûr de l'hôtellerie les hôteliers ne
sont pas contre airbnb parce que les
chambres d'hôtes existe depuis très très
longtemps les des hôteliers qui louent
viable airbnb aussi ça peut aussi y en a
mais mais disons que le concept se le
concept de meublés de tourisme ça existe
depuis très longtemps et même nous des
fois il nous arrive quand on est
vraiment très très très submergé très
bloquée sur sur versailles où on peut
faire appel
moi je me suis fait appel à des chambres
d'hôtes pour loger des clients qui était
seul qui était aucune réservation
donc le problème n'est pas de là c'est
le problème c'est de cession' et
l'équité c'est sur l'équité fiscale
c'est sur les raies la réglementation
qu'on demande aux professionnels des
charges
un hôtelier
et quelqu'un qui va mettre en location
un appartement de type airbnb ne va pas
donc pas payer les mêmes charges ccinb
absolument nous sommes soumis à l'iace
qu'un pot société nous sommes soumis à
des contrôles de sécurité des contrôles
d'hygiène aussi plein de plein de
réglementation en vigueur que ses
propriétaires de meublés s'exonère
finalement dons qu'ils ont ils ou
pratiquement les mêmes prix que nous
voire un peu moins bon dans certains cas
mais il bénéficie de ils ont qu'une
charge finale rien donc c'est ça c'est
ça que nous c'est là où la concurrence
est déloyale
ces déséquilibres estivale et c'est ce
que nous demandons à l'état et l'état je
crois que nous a pour l'instant c'est un
premier pas mais ça nous a bien répondu
par à travers la loi le maire
l'enregistrement obligatoire avec un
numéro une indifférence une
identification du bien auprès de la
commune de la d'avril 2010 est serait
loi le maire est aussi le deuxième volet
qui était bien avancé dans le cadre de
la loi sru de 2014 qui préconise à une
certain nombre de charges en cas de
changement de destination d'un bien loué
à titre commercial logo et des pratiques
mieux mieux encadrer concerne
l'application de l'observatoire du
meuble et touristique il se donne quatre
ans pour faire un état des lieux de la
situation à côté oued ces
réglementations là le fait de mettre en
place un observatoire c'est une mesure
aussi intéressante
l'observatoire c'est quoi c'est en fait
une plateforme en ligne que qui mise à
disposition des communes qu'il désire
pour aussi bien permettre aux
propriétaires d'inscrire d'enregistrer
leurs biens n'ont rien fait c'est
obligatoire et par conséquent de pouvoir
tracer de posa de pouvoir après ensuite
à la commune
suite à ces inscriptions ces
enregistrements pouvoir dire voilà nous
disposons de temps l'appartement en
location d'un touristique sur cette
commune c'est ça l'observatoire en fait
à l'encontre à versailles aujourd'hui
entre 600 et 700 annonces sur les
plateformes type airbnb absolument pour
une ville comme versailles compte plus
de 85 mille habitants est ce que c est
ce que ça représente beaucoup
oui parce que on n'y a pas beaucoup de
tel à versailles mais en même temps il
ya ils sont suffisamment présent enfin
je veux dire l'offre est suffisante
sinon on aurait des taux de remplissage
in à s'élever ce qui n'est pas le cas le
taux de remplissage à versailles autres
soit entre 55 et 70 % ce qui est au
mieux 70 % donc c'est pas formidable
c'est pas l'été au de paris donc il faut
pas non plus et cette offre vient
compléter certes l'offre d'hébergement
touristique mais il faut que ce soit
dans un cadre légal
quand vous disiez concurrence déloyale
justement est-ce que ça se ressent sur
sur la fréquentation des hôtels à
versailles oui très clairement le
week-end la clientèle loisirs le
week-end s'oriente vers ce type de
location ça c'est très net ça se toute
l'hôtellerie confondues en toutes
catégories
d'autant plus qu'à versailles le foncier
est très rare face à la demande de
logements au contraire qu' elle très
forte
exactement et c'est ça c'est ça c'est la
partie j'ai envie de dire commune c'est
que les le maire et son équipe
s'inquiète à juste titre 2-2 de la
désertification en fait un des quartiers
les skis et certains quartiers où le
commerce va très mal
même dans le quartier saint louis que je
connais très bien le commerce bon c'est
se porte pas trop mal mais c'est pas
encore formidable donc il faut pas non
plus ne faut pas il faut faire attention
à ça les écoles c'est par as des
familles qui s'implantent danser à la
place de ces logements c'est des gens
qui sont là à l'année et qui consomment
qui vont dans les écoles mais ils font
des enfants des touristes ils vont pas
forcément aller au restaurant peut-être
mais ils vont pas aller consommer tous
les jours chez le boucher chez le
charcutier chez à l'épicerie enfin c'est
du manque à gagner pour une copine dont
c'est ça répond vraiment clairement un
besoin d'un oeil après mon déménagement
alors cette décision prise à versailles
on en a parlé la loi le maire aussi qui
réglemente ce type de location
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous attendez
tête des améliorations sur la loi au
niveau peut-être nationale des décisions
à prendre encore sur le sujet tu m'as
déjà commencé à appliquer celles ci dans
toutes les communes dans plus de
communes qui sont concernés parce que je
rappelle que bordeaux a passé ses
délibérations si lyon très récemment
on paraît bien sûr depuis longtemps
depuis cette année mais il ya aussi
toulouse strasbourg puis d'autres villes
moyennes aussi un kiki nice bien sûr
nice qui est très concerné je vais vous
dire
nice c'est presque dix mille logements 1
pour nice paris c'est ça on arrive
presque à 60 mille logements
donc c'est pas rien c'est pas anodin
c'est des groupes derrière c'est plus
le petit propriétaire on n'en veut pas
nous joue enfin c'est pas une question
d'en voir mais on n'est pas là pour
contrer le le le propriétaire qui a un
appartement et qui met cet appartement
sur des plateformes c'est par ces
ballons sont prégnantes savoir plusieurs
il ya c'est le cas à versailles si les
cas les propriétaires qu'on 12 12 13
logements donc là c'est vraiment une
concurrence il nous reste un peu plus
d'une minute je voulais vous poser deux
questions un peu plus globale sur
l'hôtellerie dans les yvelines
on la suit à des émules et rend très
difficile notamment lié aux attentats de
2015 en france le secteur de
l'hôtellerie semblait subir une reprise
ce ça c'était fin 2017 est ce que sur
sept ce début d'année ça se poursuit
cette crise l'un début de l'année
n'étaient pas très bons voire des deux
premières semaines de janvier
en règle générale sur l'ensemble du
département je pense à plus ou moins ça
dépend est pas terrible bon là ça
commence à reprendre on voit on a une
meilleure visibilité mais c'est pas
encore la frénésie au niveau de la
reprise
parce qu'il s'est taillé son moi j'irai
sont plutôt bonnes puisque ils m'ont
remis il ya la gr radar cup bien sûr
mais il ya plein d'événements qui se
passe à versailles dans département
d'autres choses je pense que ça va un
peu amener du mouvement a mené des
affaires du volume d'activité merci
philippin d'avoir un père si elle vous
êtes sa hôtelier à versailles et
président de l'umih 78
c'est l'union des métiers des industries
de l'hôtellerie a dans le département à
l'orientation au programme aujourd'hui à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines la faculté de droit et des
sciences politiques basé à guyancourt
organisé à la deuxième édition de son
forum des métiers l'idée de faire
rencontrer professionnels et étudiants
de 3e année de licence et de master à
ces derniers ne sont toujours pas au
courant de l'orientation ils n'ont pas
forcément d'idées sur leur orientation
son propos propose pardon d'écouter
cette interview collectées au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude soit il le
savait de toute façon c'est utile pour
eux de rencontrer des professionnels et
d'échangés soit pour beaucoup d'entre
eux notamment en lice
ans ils ne sont pas encore sûrs de leur
projet ou parfois non pas encore donc ça
reste quand même un choix très ouvert et
nos métiers du juridique du politique
ouvre sur un panel de métiers
extrêmement important donc c'est une
forme d'orientations qui est précieuse
pour eux des propos également collectées
par quentin le frère a lu vs cul qui
accueillait également aujourd'hui une
première conversation publique entre
étudiants et la chorégraphe la
chorégraphe française maguy marin à ses
rencontres avec artistes sont à
l'initiative du collectif tête à tête
objectif faire rentrer le spectacle
vivant à l'université mélanie poquet a
suivi la rencontre du jour rocher lâcher
maguy marin figures de la danse
contemporaine se confie elle est
l'invitée d'honneur de la conversation
publique qui s'est tenue à la
bibliothèque de l'ue vs qu un retour sur
son parcours ses inspirations et ses
créations sam informe aussi de comment
les gens voient la danse ou comment les
gens voient le travail sa main forme ça
me donne des informations sur la façon
dont les gens perçoivent les choses quoi
ça m'intéresse je n'accepte plein des
conversations publiques et surtout quand
il s'agit d'étudiants toujours des
moments que j'aime beaucoup en fait ces
rencontres avec des jeunes gens ces
jeunes sont au nombre de six ils font
partie d'un collectif tête à tête qui
veut promouvoir le spectacle vivant pour
les étudiants on se rend compte que
dans les salles de spectacle c'est
toujours le même public les habitués et
en fait mine de rien le spectacle vivant
la culture ce ça amène
du lien social un aspect de vie qu'on
n'a pas forcément la danse contemporaine
on peut croire que c'est assez élitiste
en fait sauf que maguy marin elle
absolument pas vous l'avait violée hyper
généreusement ses dents serrées bruce
est allée elle dénonce en fait
énormément et c'est ça qui nous
intéressait cette conversation publique
était leur premier grand rendez vous une
conversation possible grâce au théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
robespierre victor hugo simone veil ou
encore aimé césaire de grands discours
ont marqué l'histoire de l'assemblée
nationale ces textes de femmes et
d'hommes joey starr les reprend avec sa
voix son style dans éloquence à
l'assemblée la pièce signée depuis hier
à greeley et jérémie lippmann était en
représentation hier au théâtre
montansier à versailles et camille
lambert et mikel est nu d'euros ont
rencontré et joey starr interview pas de
rap aujourd'hui pour joey starr mais du
théâtre avec son spectacle éloquence à
l'assemblée avec notamment deux grandes
figures historiques robespierre à
lamartine victor hugo pourquoi ces
grandes figures christ pourquoi non
c'est surtout le fond qui est important
enfin déjà passé pas juste les figures
et puis c'est surtout en fait quelque
chose qui m'a été proposée par pierre
grillet jérémie lippmann et au départ
pierre grillet revisitait tu ces grands
hommes qui ont été et qui ont fait qu'on
est et qui ont fait de la politique et
qui aussi les qu'artiste me côté donc
voilà il a eu l'idée c'était un peu plus
d'un an m demeure avec l richard mille
mano mettra en scène et ne me proposait
et c'est important que les discours
sortent des bâtiments institutionnels
mais bien sûr investiture importants
comme on avait pu donner le ton dans le
théâtre il ya même des gens qui se
déplacent ici ce n'est pas forcément au
théâtre parce que c'est moi et autres
bien sûr que c'est important que ça
ça arrive à tous c'est l'un des
objectifs de la pièce moi j'ai déjà dit
tout ce que je fais je le fais pour moi
je fais pour moi principalement et parce
que ça m'intéresse c'est parce que voilà
après si gens convergent dessus c'est
génial mais par je ne pense pas ce genre
de choses quoi rêvez-vous ce qui est
triste c'est que c'est sur le peuple
que pèse la peine de mort vous avez été
obligé dites vous isabelle dans un
plateau de la balance ignorance et la
misère
il fallait un contrepoids dans notre
plateau il y avait mis la peine de mort
est bien noté la peine de mort vous va
la forcer forcé entendez-vous de taux si
les nuances et la misère vous êtes
condamnés à toutes ces améliorations à
la fois alors le théâtre montansier a
été créé en 1777
est ce que le discours à plus de
résonance ici dans un lieu historique
comme celui là oui mon joueur aussi on
veut quoi mais pour moi que ce soit que
j'ai le jouer à anjou ou hameaux ou
voilà maintenant après effectivement
c'est le premier théâtre c'est surtout
pour moi c'est ce dont je trouve que
c'est surtout on négocie ça flatte et
puis voilà quoi mais après après comme
je le disais moi ce qu'il nous ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que tout ça tout ça
soit porté le de manière avérée juste et
je veux dire si c'est une première ici
pour vous un versailles
c'est une première pour moi versés et du
coup quel est le discours que vous avez
le plus est née sur ces sas ferrand mois
l'humeur ça change en bien sûr j'ai bien
sûr une présentation
ouais ouais ça ce pas l'humeur mais
c'est sûr que j'ai une affection
particulière pour pour aimé césaire par
exemple voilà mais sinon il faut savoir
que pour certains discours comme celui
d'olympe de gouges qu'elle n'a pas pu
livrer ou robespierre ou je reste les
gens sont morts le lendemain voire
quelques jours après quoi donc on sent
que déjà on est plus on n'est pas dans
la dynamique du jour d'hui où on a des
énarques qui sont ou des politiciens qui
sont des managers et le privé a pris le
pas sur public d'endettement alors que
on sent qu'il ya des relances a déjà ces
époques en 1700 autres mais on sent
qu'il ya plus de militantisme plus de
ventre plus de coeur enfin voilà quoi et
comment fait on se met dans la peau de
ses personnages ses personnages déjà
comme je le disais au départ on peut on
peut et c'est déjà comme je le disais au
départ ce sont des gens c'est des gens
qui comptent ont écrit pour le théâtre
ou qu'on écrit toukourou voilà donc on
sent que dans l'écriture
quelque chose de très théâtral même si
ça reste de la politique même s'ils sont
là pour informer annoncé imposer aux
autres
il ya quelque chose de dax de très
théâtral déjà donc de fait à part
robespierre qui est avocat voilà tous
les autres dont du coût et du coup ça du
coup c'est écrit avec avec une certaine
verve en phase
enfin voilà quoi donc donc c'est ce qui
me permet peut-être de trouver ne porte
pour pouvoir y accéder
il ya un jour dans l'année où le plus
imperceptibles citoyens ou la tonne
social participe à la vie heymans du
pays tout entier ou la bise et 3
poitrine se dilate allaire vaste et des
affaires publiques
[Musique]
un jour le plus faible
sans lui la grandeur de la souveraineté
nationale
et qu'est ce quelle éloquence selon vous
c'est le corps la voix les deux à la
fois les silences la posture c'est plein
de choses c'est plein de paramètres le
corps aussi jouent un rôle oui je vous
ai joué et est ce que la mise en scène
vous êtes tout seul
du coup sur scène est ce que ça apporte
un autre aura encore plus bas
heureusement sinon ça fait inutile
j'adore devant le théâtre est pas dans
le théâtre
oui non oui tout à fait la misère
aisance et un autre pour le coup est
très moderne très simple très sobre
c'est ce que j'aime et bien sûr que
celle ahmed ammor gcc j'ai joué dans la
dans la salle des pas perdus à la gare
saint-lazare plein de lumière machin
vers 18 heures bon voilà je me sentais
un peu amoindri parce qu'il n'est pas là
des anciennes et je pense que même pour
les gens qui rentraient chez eux comme
ça voilà le truc était là parce que
j'étais curieux à propos du dos de ce
que je pouvais là voilà mais je
sais que si on avait pu avoir des
rideaux machin tout le truc la mise en
scène il ya un dialogue direct aussi
inquiet public vous le public savoure à
berne
ça parle forcément d'éloquence votre
votre spectacle
est-ce que l'éloquence ou qu'est ce que
ça représente qu'est ce que ça
représente ce qu'on pense
éloquence je pense qu'on a manqué ce qu
est ce qu il y as qu'il ya des mots sur
lesquels je sais pas où vous avez
insisté peut-être dans votre spectacle
il n'y a pas de mot sur les casinos
systeia je pense que tout les doutes
épousé de dahmane et enfin au groupe ou
possible de la manière dont ça a été
livré par les auteurs l'éloquence et là
c'est la manière de livrer comme j'ai
pas leur coûter dans les silences la
posture c'est l'intention quoi
l'éloquence et l'intention tout court
quoi c'est l'intention c'est bon aller
au camp c'est aussi la ville en deux
dans l'échangé enfin voilà dana question
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que les gens
prennent à une sortie spectacle il y
avait 70 sujet j'ai pas de gpg pas de
vérité ou de voter propres qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient c'est parce que les gens
retiennent cgt cette légende on va dire
pour ceux qui ne vont pas au théâtre et
sont là les curieux peut-être mais si ça
peut réveiller certaines consciences
citoyennes qui sommeille en eux wes
après tout ça peut être bien sinon ouais
mais ça prenne un parce que je les 6 et
5 1 le libre cours à sa perception de
quoi voilà dans lequel beaucoup
l'entretien de camille lambert et
michael et le lido ro c'est un événement
national la nuit des conservatoires 2018
se déroule ce vendredi elle prendra
place également à saint quentin en
yvelines à l'école de musique et de
danse de trappes participe au
rendez-vous en proposant des portes
ouvertes expositions et concerts alors
castres helios sera en représentation
dans le cadre d'une programmation hors
les murs de la merise on écoute la
directrice de l'école elle était
l'invité hier du 7-8 culture de mélanie
poquet
elle commence à 17 heures et elle se
terminera certainement vers 23 heures et
se prolongera le lendemain nous avons
pris la décision de faire une nuit des
conservatoires prolonger le samedi avec
notre événement phare tempo pour avoir
voilà notre week-end festif convivial
qui puisse accueillir le public et qui
viennent découvrir en fait tout ce que
l'on peut proposer au sein de l'école de
musique et des danses et plus
d'informations sur cette nuit des
conservatoires attrape sur le site
internet qui s'affiche
on referme cette page culture avec le
costume il peut être déguisements
masques et même à parra à la ferme du
mousseau à elancourt exposé depuis le 19
janvier ses oeuvres interrogeant cette
notion du costume des habits
traditionnels qui deviennent des
performances et des oeuvres d'art comme
vous allez le voir avec ce sujet de
mélanie poker
[Musique]
des ébauches des croquis le point de
départ de la conception du costume qu'il
soit d'apparat ou traditionnels il est
au coeur de l'exposition résonances des
longs cours on est vraiment sur cette
idée là de quelque chose que l'on porte
sur soi mais que l'on porte devant un
public 1 dans l'idée de costumes ya
vraiment l'idée d'être en spectacle
même pour traverser la rue
éventuellement voilà ça dépend si on
envisage cette traversée de la rue comme
une performance mais pourquoi pas
où
des costumes résolument contemporain ces
artistes franciliens sont exposés
six femmes plasticienne et costumière
mais aussi des travaux d'élèves ceux de
l'école d'arts plastiques de la commune
j'ai souhaité les faire travailler eux
aussi sur cette notion de costumes
justement on a beaucoup travaillé déjà
sur la différence entre le costume labit
le vêtement et puis on a expérimenté
comme matière le papier on a essayé de
voir un petit peu tout ce qu'on pouvait
faire avec du papier et ils ont
découvert des choses incroyables de la
peinture à la sculpture résonance emmène
sur les podiums de défilés de mode dans
le rapport vêtements peau et place le
costume dans la lumière
une rencontre insolite à présent jean
claude klein g est archéologue ils
collectent différentes pierres et des
objets datant de la préhistoire ce
collectionneur a décidé depuis cinq ans
d'exposer ces objets à la boissière
école michael et demi d'euros nicolas
landry et camille lambert
voilà une meule néolithique le
néolithique ce sont les premiers pays
l'an c'était l'outil utilisé par les
agriculteurs de la préhistoire pour
fabriquer de la farine 1 objets datant
de plus de 6000 ans découverts au maroc
par jean claude klein g
j'ai vraiment notre notre passé quoi de
la farine on en fait toujours
aujourd'hui
et l'époque c'était donc les inventeurs
de dupas en fin de compte
passionné d'archéologie jean claude
klein j'ai c'est un peu lyndiane à jones
yvelinois il possède près de 800 pièces
des silex des lames aiguisées et des
fossiles plusieurs trésors de la
préhistoire découvert lors de recherches
une activité qu'il exerce depuis la fin
des années 70 et c'est de savoir de
connaître l'âge savoir quel type d'homme
la réaliser donc il faut il faut
chercher dans les normes et livres dans
les archives de quelle période ça peut
ça peut être
et après il faut faire le dessin de ce
de cet objet et faire un rapport de
prospection un document obligatoire
après une découverte a envoyé à la
direction régionale des affaires
culturelles ou au centre de recherche
archéologique de la région mantaise jean
claude klein g peut ensuite exposé ses
trouvailles dans sa petite maison en
bois de la boissière école un musée
qu'ils continuent d'alimenter à travers
ces chasses au trésor une bonne nouvelle
sportive pour refermer ce journal marvin
petit et bien le nouveau champion
intercontinental des poids légers à la
ceinture du boxeur saint quentinois a
été confirmée par la wb a et la
fédération française samedi dernier dans
le 92 il avait remporté son combat au
septième round par ko contre samir kasmi
mais une bagarre générale avait éclaté
dans la salle entre des supporters avec
la confirmation de cette victoire marvin
petit intègre donc le top 15 mondial
dans sa catégorie
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal à
suivre ce soir sur notre antenne un
débat consacré au retrait de la
candidature de la france à l'exposition
universelle 2025 c'est à suivre
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]